[Music]
now Blake Shelton's surprises fans
dropping in to perform at bars in
Nashville
[Applause]
[Music]
country superstar was flying solo no
girlfriend Gwen Stefani insight as he
posed for pics with fans at a meet and
greet event at one point late even got
behind the bar to pour drinks two nights
ago at the CMT Awards Blake was spotted
backstage with the Smith works vodka cup
he's a brand ambassador I've been
keeping all the letters that he wrote to
you we were with him as he performed at
an LA bar last year and we all know
Blake enjoys his adult beverages I just
don't picture you and like alcohol is
that right why have you been in a coma
the last few years or what I like vodka
so this is luck you know that's a
no-brainer for me right I think like
every interview that I've done with you
you've actually had like vodka that's
right that's right and Blake was
grateful we've shown him sipping from a
cup from time to time Thank You Nancy
cuz we show him without little red cups
got vodka and that's right
yeah I love you ah there you go that's
why we love you too
[Music]
you